good evening it is our pleasure to
present the Oscar for best achievement
in film editing and with all due respect
to Jack I'd like to say doesn't totally
have the corner on the coolest guy in
the room market Thank You Ashley it's
important to remember the editors
because without the work of these
talented artists this year's movies
might have been really long and here are
the nominees
tareeq anwar and Christopher green berry
for American Beauty Lisa
xeno Gergen for The Cider House Rules
William Goldenberg Paul Bluebell and
David rosenbloom for The Insider
Zac Steinberg for the matrix and Ramon
shine for the Sixth Sense and the Oscar
goes to
Zac Steinberg for the matrix
first Oscar nomination for Zach
Steinberg
thank you very much it's really while
being up here Thank You Larry and Andy
Wachowski for your vision creativity
intelligence daily inspiration and most
of all your friendship you accomplish
the seemingly impossible a movie with
action suspense and an intelligent
provocative message take the blue pill
and stay where you are
or take the red pill and see just how
deep the rabbit-hole goes
we had a great team quite a few of whom
have been honored here tonight
they made my work great I'd like to
thank Loretta
Lorenzo de Bona Ventura and everybody at
Warner Brothers for the creative freedom
and support Joel silver and Barry
Osborne for fighting some good fights in
our behalf my entire assistant editing
team led by Peter Skerritt you all know
who you are thanks to my wife Bonnie my
son Robert I love you there is no spoon